[Musique]
on les surnomme les sentinelles de
l'environnement car les abeilles
pollinisent plus de 80% des plantes qui
nous entoure mais depuis une trentaine
d'années maintenant ces sentinelles sont
en danger décimés par usage intensif de
produits phytosanitaires et l'apparition
de parasites et de nouveaux prédateurs
pour les protéger le département
s'engage auprès de l'union nationale de
l'apiculture française en signant la
charte
l'abeille sentinelle de l'environnement
bien sûr ne pas utiliser de pesticides
ne pas utiliser d'eau gm parce qu'on
sait que les ogm sont quand même
toxiques favoriser l'implantation des
plantes mellifères mais ça vous le
faites au delà de nos espérances
encourager la connaissance de la bei de
l'apiculture il ya de plus en plus
d'initiatives pédagogiques et notamment
la réunion dont vous êtes en plein dans
la charte développer l'information aux
agriculteurs sur le rôle pollinisateur
l'art ya encore du travail mais les
choses bougent quand même quant à petit
promouvoir leurs deux labels comme
certains environnements et aider à
l'installation nouvelle colis nouveaux
apiculteurs donc vous remplissez
parfaitement la charte donc écouter aux
élèves voilà vous êtes de très bons
élèves les actions phares du département
c'est bien évidemment le programme un
million d'arbres donc le département
s'investit dans la plantation d'arbres
indigènes et endémiques mellifères pour
la préservation des abeilles le
département accompagne la filière
apicole et notamment à travers aussi le
des programmes d'actions de
sensibilisation pour le grand public et
pour les scolaires département nous aide
énormément notamment en mettant à la
disposition des apiculteurs des espaces
où on peut émettre des ruches dans les
concessions notamment des espaces
naturels sensibles dont je suis certain
que le département le départ demain est
également le plus gros propriétaire
terrien donc on a effectivement un gros
partenariat à m on a mis en place le
département et qui nous répond de belle
manière puisque j'ai pas le nombre exact
de concessions nombreuses concessions en
forêt mascarin jardin botanique est un
site de découverte qui dispose de trois
rucher pédagogique et de plantes
mellifères endémique la réunion compte
600 apiculteurs pour une production
annuelle de 250 tonnes de riz